you had perhaps my worst fear and every
guy's worst fear happened to you do you
know what i'm talking about yeah yeah
you burned your [ __ ] and balls yeah
you were working on a movie called the
eagle right the scottish highlands it
was freezing out the way i understand it
and it was so cold that a lot of the
guys would take warm water and pour it
down their pants
some [ __ ] uh handed you uh the cup of
warm water that you could pour down your
pants except he forgot to tell you that
it was scalding hot water scalding hot
right yeah boiling boiling uh what
happened next
uh i started hyperventilating and
screaming and jumping into back into the
river because it was a hypothermic river
and we had wetsuits on which is the
worst part about it and uh and so
this this poor guy though i got to be
honest
look i i i know i know but he had been
for 13 hours running up a hill for like
15 minutes like to boil this huge like
bottle of water fill it half full with
like actual kettle water
run back down the muddy hill and then
fill up the like put the river water in
it and then come over to me just to keep
me warm
right and then what we wrapped the day i
started walking up the hill and what had
happened he just didn't get all the way
down right so we had been 13 hours of
the same thing every time we saw each
other and he's like you want to warm up
for the walk uh for the walk up and and
of course i was like yeah why not and uh
just oh it was it was the worst thing
how long does it take like when you know
when you burn your finger and it just
keeps burning
so it it kept burning for the next like
probably 20 to 30 minutes like i was
having a complete panic attack because
you think you're losing your dick yeah
well
that was one one of the ambulance dudes
uh he was like he was like look man i
know this is no [ __ ] consolation i
can't do a scottish accent uh he's like
i know this is
i know there's no consolation now mate
but uh it's a good thing that it hurts
otherwise you've got nerve damage
i couldn't even i just couldn't and then
there happened to be a radio playing and
um i'll give you three guesses if you
haven't read it in an interview already
what song it was on what was it my your
sex is on fire oh no come on i swear to
you that is [ __ ] crazy that is that
exact actual song the driver was like
maybe we should change this no how long
does it take for that to heal where you
can actually bang again uh i would say i
was i was good almost a week later yeah
a week you were banging again yeah wow
yeah i mean look it wasn't it was it was
a little rough but we've got we got it
done tell you something that's very
masculine
i'll be honest i i do i think i've never
used yours
i'm such a baby i'm such a baby if i
burn my [ __ ] like that i'd wait a year
you'd still be complaining you don't
remind you of like wolverine maybe uh
you know the one you just skin here
it's just my dick though are you
circumcised
are you circumcised uh yes you are yes
and it's still healed that fast still
healed that fast everything foreign
[Music]
the doctor gave me these bandages and i
was like okay cool so i put the bandages
around it and i didn't think that you
know i didn't put any of that gauze or
whatever oh no i went down to the bar
like the next day and uh i was having
drinking beer and then and the next
thing you know you gotta you gotta go to
the bathroom yeah you gotta take a peek
and uh so i went to the bathroom and i
realized that i
i didn't get all the tape on to the
gauze like i
so it was on the bottom
it was and i'm sorry
basically on my knees in a bathroom in a
pub like in in scotland
it's so sad like i'm peeing in my
shriveled
oh my god i can't think of oh
what did i do
you